parlons un peu de cet étonnant salon qui
se tient depuis hier à paris celui de la
restauration rapide ce qu'on appelle
aussi pour être encore plus rapide le
fast-food rapide c'est sûr bones t'avoir
efficace en tout cas c'est évident des
millions de français s'alimente
désormais comme ça tous les jours
martine gilson ces deux hommes manches
face rapide si vous préférez une formule
inventée aux usa par mcdonald's mcdo
pour les initiés et qui débarque en
france dans les années 70 une percée
timide d'abord qui dérange la france du
cassoulet et du jambon beurre et puis
depuis deux ans
le boom quelques chiffres 12 millions et
demi de longueur avalé en 1981 1 million
800 mille pour le seul mois d'août 80
dans la région parisienne deux par
seconde
la france ne des jeunes ont pu l aval
deux explications à ce boom le style de
vie d'abord et puis surtout la crise
quand tout coûte plus cher on se sert
l'estomac
vous êtes ici à barbès dans ce mac
donald 2500 clients défilent chaque jour
[Musique]
si tous âges et pour les grands
qui n'ont pas beaucoup de sous en
principe alors
si c'est pour manger ivoire il faut
qu'elle se bat là-bas
sap et j'aime ça
les gens viennent quand même parce
qu'ailleurs ya pas moins cher à payer
je
je pense que ce chiffre correspondait à
un besoin
restaurant classique devenait de plus en
plus cher
ça correspondait exactement à la bourse
on vient ici
entre la fin
je pense oui fond
on vient quand on a faim
manger souvent
mal plus mettre d'eau recevoir
c'est ce qu'il ya dedans
vous avez vous avez le
vous avez le
le guide mc après les jeunes les cadres
se sont mis aux fastes après les grosses
chaînes américaines les petits
commerçants français se sont mis hors
amm burger dans cette rue paisible du
16e arrondissement
trois jeunes gens tous verts il y a un
an ce qui leur donne le nom sonne
amérique le quitta le goût du mcdo mais
ici on s'assoit la française et la
clientèle et surtout grosse des employés
et cadres qui peuplent de quartier la
crise oblige
[Musique]
plus en plus les gens ou un budget repas
en moyenne de 17 francs qui correspond
aux tickets restaurant ils ne peuvent
pas trouver dans une restauration
classique les moyens d'avoir un repas
complet pour cette somme est dans un
fast-food vous faites un repas tout à
fait complet pour la somme de 17 francs
maxime d'autres français ont imaginé eu
une formule rapide mais bien de chez
nous comme lui de du pdg de la brioche
dorée
j'ai préféré si vous voulez prendre un
produit qui soit typiquement français et
essayer d'adapter un produit
ce produit de la vente à partir de rio
chez du croissant on essaie de ré
artisanat lisez le produit est
d'industrialiser la gestion la brioche
avec ou contre le hamburger en 1981 lui
le du faf et 75 millions de chiffre
d'affaires cette année il va le doublé
cet été aussi il va ouvrir une
briocherie à new york
étrange retour des choses tandis que les
français continueront de se nourrir au
ram burger les américains eux vont
manger du croissant
[Musique]